un slogan des pancartes qui vont avec et
des foules dans les rues en novembre
2012 un nouveau mouvement se structure
la manif pour tous très médiatique
à l'origine elle lutte contre les
projets de loi d'ouverture du mariage
aux couples homosexuels ne pousseront
pas au code civil pour sa première
manifestation la manif pour tous
revendiquent 100 mille manifestants dans
toute la france
elle se structure très vite le mouvement
rassemble plusieurs associations il se
veut apolitique ouvert à toutes les
sensibilités
parmi ces figures au départ béatrice
bourges militante catholique présidente
du collectif pour l'enfant
le ciment de la société c'est la famille
ou bien laurent stien hng présidente de
la gauche pour le mariage républicain
le gouvernement est déterminé il ne nous
écoute pas et xavier bongibault
militants de la manif pour tous
lui même homosexuel je suis athée est
homosexuel donc on a réussi à faire
tomber tous les clichés mais la figure
de la manif pour tous celle qui a
orchestré la médiatisation du mouvement
certaines nous est frigide barjot
l'argent bon c'est pas vraiment votre
nom et votre nom de scène en scène votre
nom de scène puisque vous êtes
humoristes vous êtes comment dire une
anar de droite une catho nanar d'amour
mais une anarchiste c'est vrai dans
celle bien rentré mettre les pieds dans
le plat en tout cas les pieds les mets
partout il y à des manifestants a
rameuté jusque dans les échos
tout le monde donc à la manif pour tous
le 13 janvier de 13 janvier 2013
la manif pour tous revendique 340 mille
manifestants pour renforcer ses rangs à
paris et grossir les foules dans les 10
heures des caméras l'association
organise depuis toute la france des
convois en car et en train bien 5 heures
du matin 5
5 arrêté demandant
forte de son succès médiatique elle
attire d'autres cortèges qu'elle a voulu
tenir à l'écart
parmi eux les catholiques intégristes de
civitas mais aussi des politiques de
droite et d'extrême droite
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le peuple
souverain à sa voix à dire entre 2012 et
la manif pour tous a fait l'objet de 227
reportage dans les jt de 19 et 20 heures
peu à peu les politiques et les franges
intégristes se sont fondus dans le
mouvement
les figures historiques qui ont quitté
l'association mais la force de frappe du
mouvement a perduré bien situé